va bene allora vi spiego questa cosa che
ultimamente sul web ho visto un sacco di
video dove c'è gente che sfascia il mio
numero di telefono
tralasciando il fatto che tutte le cose
che trovate su internet del tipo il
numero di telefono di famiglia e sono
minchiate assurde perché non ce n'è uno
vero ma neanche uno potevo andare a
commentare questi ragazzi che spacciano
il mio fake numero per far virus viene
detto che nessuno scrive il
la prima comunale prima cosa che esce il
numero di falli geni ma state male il
numero di falli gemma bene andiamo che
adesso il numero di fan ejei 225.000
virus questo quanto chiamato amici al
telefono vediamo svariate e
accuratissime ricerche con quale musica
di sottofondo me lo stai dicendo sono
riuscito a trovare qualche numero che
potrebbe essere corretto per riuscirci
e ciao a tutti ragazzi sono matiz e
benvenuti in lega guarda io sono sicuro
ovviamente che risponderà certa mi posso
dire di aver parlato con lo youtuber più
famoso d'italia dopo me ovviamente
[Musica]
questo è il primo numero perché hai
censurato il mio numero con il mio
numero con una fetta di prosciutto
gigante andiamo a chiamarlo che mosca
c'è anche il numero delle chiamate non è
abilitato al traffico è fatto chissà
perché ma quando tutto sembrava perduto
perché l'ha trovato ragazzi ha squillato
potrebbe essere veramente lui o io o
incredibile riproviamo un'altra volta
minchia dai silvio
quanto tempo fa vincelli macro sta cosa
sembrava un bambino di 12 anni cosa fa
vincere ma anche solo dalla voce come
potrei pensare che fossi io come cioè
sentite voci a parigi ma come no i sogni
di questo ragazzo andati distrutti
poverino il numero nypa nigeria e 36 66
66 48 asino cotto c'è abbondanza di
comicità ultimamente su youtube c'è chi
ha fatto anche mezzo milione di più che
bene come avrete già belletto dal titolo
oggi mi veniva dal profondo qui da qui
ha ri no io voglio vedere quella volta
che risponde una donna e poi il ragazzo
in questione risponde fabi ha ri ha
trovato il numero su facebook questo
dovrebbe essere il numero di falli j
quest'anno a capire neanche il cazzo sta
dicendo questo è il numero di falli j
vabbè dai basta ho chiamato famigie in
diretta 187mila prima donna come facile
fare le viuzze rega scusa mi sbatte
quello di destra di uomini e poi si
tocca
quello sinistro ti sei fatto mara
l'altro braccio si è sbagliato e un
giorno non so che a fantasma tutto un
altro uomo quello sbattuto si tocca
l'altro perché hai il numero di fa
vigenti ma se non segna e scrivere il
mio nickname
perché scrivi il numero di fa vj con la
gen maiuscola non sai neanche qual è il
mio nickname
stiamo ma la chat ok ciao c6 un'amica di
un tuo amico chi volete che cosa sto
bevendo ma sincero con i j
si mangia tete con me non voglio ma cui
materiale in numero ma non citare con me
non voglio subito il secondo dopo ma
come fate ad avere il mio numero ce ne
sono anche incoerente con le mie scelte
ma non voglio chattare con tempera come
stai
vivace telai che vi svelo e lioni fa vj
vento ciao ragazzi cosa cazzo ho visto
cento laica che sebbene al numero di
fatih cei 1515 live dove è fottutamente
il mio numero dober il numero di far
fare qualcosa scrivere il mio cazzo di
nome ma si è fatto un video sul mio
numero nemmeno spiega quali j
giusto ma uno che scrive a quali genio
giacché mischi diciamo ma se infatti
dov'è morta la insieme a marco io ancora
spessore sia marco dove le basi loro
posso farti forse posso chiederti una
cortesia amico mirics xv al 27 con 101
iscritti e 37.000
questo video se devi impersonare me con
una chat finta almeno ti prego ti
scongiuro mettile h nei derby ti prego
non mi fai passare per un analfabeta
almeno lacca nella nell'iper cherchi
cazzola messo la l'ha messo laccato
vetta dove la iii nel nome dove lacca
nei derby perché mancano le lettere in
questo video sono tornato ieri dalle tre
a los angeles ho scoperto governo
diciamo abbastanza ha scoperto
abbastanza scoperto solo un po non del
tutto un pochettino scoperto coperto
diciamo abbastanza il numero air alcuni
youtuber che ho incontrato non gabbo
dredd c'erano friggerà loro nel titolo
non ci sono c'è solo fa vj perché parli
dei pac lì che gli altri non lo fanno e
che se volete i numeri diversi di questi
si iscrive temi al canale se lasciate
likes ieri nei commenti si rivede extra
e scritto con dice ancora youtuber che
volete che rimanga suo numero
ma secondo te la gente
veramente ci casca in questa minchiata
incredibile se io vado nei commenti
secondo te qualcuno ha scritto mamma
voglio morire ma per ragazzi dire che
per oggi basta voglio andare a finire le
patatine che non è educato mangiare
dante il vino se non placement sta roba
però non è un privilegio per oggi per un
figo capitali sia piaciuto ragazzi per
oggi conclude con il numero di telefono
di parigi spero che siate tutti contenti
di aver visto che non esiste il mio
numero sul web però è impossibile da
trovare a meno che non abbiate una terza
anche abbastanza fondate in quel caso
domandatevi un direct e io vi rispondo
con i ragazzi insieme aceto guida
l'assenza di cielo ci metto anche come
descrizione certo che si rischia temi e
noi ci vediamo proseguito dai ragazzi
[Musica]